Hallo! Heute gibt's den Carrot Cake von Starbucks.
Ich hab ihn mir extra gekauft!
(H: Es ist keine...?)
Keine?
(H: Bezahlte...?)
Produktplatzierung!
(H: Produktplatzierung!)
Es ist sogar möglich, dass ihr gerade meinen Magen knurren hören habt
weil man Mikro hier ist und mein Magen hier und ich habe richtig Hunger und ich werd' den gleich
zum Mittagessen verspeisen!
So, auf jeden Fall haben wir uns den geholt, dann kann man nachher nämlich auch schön
den Geschmackstest machen! Das geben wir erstmal zur Seite
und ich starte jetzt mit dem saftigen  Karottenkuchen. Der muss richtig saftig sein, also es ist wirklich ein Muss
und ich gebe jetzt hier zuallererst Eier - die sind auf Raumtemperatur - in die Küchenmaschine.
So, zusammen mit dem Zucker und dann schlage ich das ca 5min lang richtig schön hell-cremig.
So, dann ganz kurz das Öl einrühren und jetzt kommen wir zu den trockenen Zutaten.
Übrigens: alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben, die findet ihr immer unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Einfach den Titel aufklappen und dann seht ihr sie!
Und jetzt habe ich hier einmal Mehl, Back-Kakao, dann gebe ich da noch Backpulver dazu und Zimt,
ich finde Zimt darf nicht fehlen!
So, einmal grob vorab verrühren und dann mit zur Eiermasse sieben und auch nur ganz kurz einrühren.
So, nachdem ihr die trockenen Zutaten nur ganz kurz eingerührt habt auch noch Vanilleextrakt dazugeben
und jetzt habe ich hier erst mal den vorerst fertigen Teig,
der muss jetzt aber noch aufgepimpt werden natürlich mit Karotten,
die habe ich hier fein geraspelt. Die gebe ich hier direkt dazu. Außerdem Walnüsse und Rosinen.
Ich bin ganz ehrlich: ich bin kein großer Rosinen-Fan, deswegen habe ich bei mir jetzt ein bisschen weniger
rein gegeben. Wenn ihr Rosinen mögt, dann -
(H: Ich danke dir dafür!)
Ja du magst die auch nicht, ne?
(H: Mit Schokolade vielleicht!)
Ja, mit Schokolade überzogen gehen sie! So, dann gebe ich die noch dazu.
Ihr könnt die Mengen wirklich variieren, ihr könnt auch mehr Walnüsse und weniger Rosinen reingeben
oder gar keine Rosinen! So, jetzt hebe ich das ganz kurz unter und dann können wir das auch schon backen!
Also wie man hier deutlich sehen kann, hat man hier viel Bodenanteil.
Also 4 Böden sind's und die sind auch nicht gerade dünn! Daher mache ich's so,
dass ich den Boden jetzt in 2 Tortenringen backe. Ihr könntet auch Springformen nehmen, vollkommen egal!
Habe ich jetzt auf 20cm eingestellt und ich mache das deswegen unterteilt auf 2 Tortenringe
damit die gleichmäßig backen. Wenn ihr jetzt die Masse in einem Tortenring backen würdet,
dann würde die an der Oberfläche total austrocknen, dunkel werden
und in der Mitte wahrscheinlich gar nicht gar werden.
Und aus dem Grund machen wir das so. Und ihr könnt den Ofen auch schon mal vorheizen,
180° C Ober- und Unterhitze, das ist ganz wichtig. Und dann backt er so für ungefähr 45min,
macht gerne die Stäbchenprobe
So meine Süßen! Während jetzt der Boden abkühlt kümmern wir uns um das Cream-Cheese Frosting.
Dafür benötigen wir zimmerwarme Butter, die ich jetzt zuallererst in der Küchenmaschine aufschlagen werde.
Ich gucke gleich auf den Timer und sag euch dann, wie viele Minuten es gedauert hat.
Wichtig ist, dass es jetzt wirklich richtig schön hell-cremig  ist und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder!
So, 7 - 7 ½min dauert das Ganze in der Maschine und die Butter ist richtig schön hell-cremig geworden,
genau so muss sie sein.
Und jetzt nehmen wir uns Doppelrahmfrischkäse.
Wichtig ist: bitte bitte nicht die Light-Variante oder irgendwas fettarmes nehmen,
es muss wirklich die Doppelrahmstufe sein an Frischkäse.
Gebe ich jetzt mit dazu, nur ganz kurz einrühren! Nicht zu viel, sonst wird es flüssig.
Dann Vanilleextrakt dazugeben - sehr wichtig für den Geschmack -
und anschließend Puderzucker, das ich vorher gesiebt habe.
So und dann ist das Frosting eigentlich auch schon fertig!
So, das Frosting ist jetzt fertig und wenn es bei euch ein bisschen weicher ist als gedacht
- weil sollte schon sehr fest sein - dann einfach in die Kühlung geben für ½h oder 1h in den Kühlschrank,
immer wieder umrühren. Bei mir ist das jetzt auch der Fall weil es hier ziemlich warm ist, die Lichter sind an
und ich mach das gleich auch so. Und in der Zwischenzeit
unsere saftigen Böden einmal durchschneiden.
Und können wir mal bitte heute über unsere Tortensäge sprechen?
Ich bin heute mal wieder so stolz darauf, dass wir die eben haben! Es hat sich einmal mehr herausgestellt,
dass es wichtig ist eben, dass das Produkt gut ist! Ihr habt jetzt hier keinen Draht, der euch einfach kaputt geht
und ihr immer wieder Ersatz braucht sondern eine echte Klinge!
Also einen Wellenschliff haben wir hier und das kann eben auch die Nüsse durchschneiden
und ich finde das sieht auch super super schön aus, ich liebäugel hier schon die ganze Zeit damit!
Und im nächsten Schritt ganz einfach alles füllen! Also super easy: Boden, Frosting, Boden, Frosting.
Und auch außen einmal komplett glatt streichen und dann sind wir fast fertig!
Was ihr unbedingt nicht wegwerfen dürft sind die Reste von eurem geschnittenen Boden.
Die Überreste, die oben liegen bleiben, die brauchen wir nämlich gleich noch!
So jetzt habe ich hier noch den übrig gebliebenen Tortenboden. Das war der Abschluss oben,
den ihr einfach gerade weggeschnitten habt. Und den jetzt einfach mit den Händen richtig fein zerbröseln
und an den Rand der Torte quasi "dran kleben". Also ich habe jetzt nur diese 2 Stücke
und ich finde komischerweise auch im Internet keinen ganzen Carrot Cake, also kein Foto davon.
Aber anhand der Stücke habe ich gesehen, dass die's so gemacht haben
und deswegen machen wir das auch so!
So, anschließend ca 20min kühlen, dann wird die Oberfläche auch schön fest
und dann könnt ihr mit weißer Kuvertüre und einer kleinen Lochtülle  ganz einfach
das Rautenmuster aufspritzen, so ist es ja im Original auch.
Und dann seid ihr fertig und ihr könnt euren Carrot Cake genießen!
Wir machen's jetzt so: wir werden jetzt erst mal diese Endszenen shooten,
also der Hamza. Du machst das dann gleich, ne?
(H: M-hm!)
Und die Fotos etc. und dann probieren wir natürlich Original und meins -
Oh jetzt ist es glaub ich ein bisschen schief!
Es ist so! Es ist wie es ist!
(H: Der Akku ist leer geworden!)
Hamzas Gimbal Akku ist leer gegangen! Aber wir machen professionell weiter, ist nicht schlimm!
Was ich sagen wollte: wir probieren das gleich auf Instagram weil wie gesagt
muss noch geshootet werden. Und wenn ihr uns auf Instagram noch nicht folgt,
dann holt das doch jetzt schnell nach! Dann habt ihr die Szenen schon gesehen.
Ansonsten werden wir sie euch am Ende des Videos einfügen
und dann den ehrlichen Geschmackstest machen. Und wir werden auch wirklich ehrlich sein, ne?
(H: *lacht* Auf jeden Fall!)
Auf jeden Fall!
Okay, ganz viel Freude euch beim Nachmachen, ich verabschiede mich schonmal offiziell
(H: Ja bitte schnell, meine Hand tut weh!)
Okay, okay, Hamzas Hand tut weh
also bis zum nächsten Mal und bleibt bis zum Schluss dran!
Tschüss!
Ehrliche Meinung: Ich kann's verstehen warum die Leute das nachmachen wollen.
Das schmeckt echt gut die Torte, also beide! Aber ich find dein's einfach frischer.
Schmeckt echt frischer, man merkt diese Frische, da sind nur frische Zutaten dabei. Hier ist es einfach nur:
man merkt, dass es einfach von draußen gekauft ist. Egal ob das jetzt fertig gekauft ist
bei irgendeiner Konditorei oder keine Ahnung, bei Starbucks.
Man merkt, dass es industriell gemacht wurde. Ich merke das einfach sofort!
Und bei dir ist einfach diese Liebe die man schmeckt.
Ist so!
(K: Okay, was möchtest du Schatzi?
Kaffee, Tee, soll ich dir irgendwas machen?)
Nö!
(K: *lacht*)
Ich möcht' ein...jaa!
(K: Ich geb dir 100 Punkte!)
Hab ich gut gemacht, ne?
(K: Ja, hast du gut gemacht!)
Ich hab gut gelogen, ne?
Der schmeckt viel geiler, ich schwöre!
(K: *lacht*)